let's move on now to some other
right-wing figures who were just gushing
or defending or very impressed with
vladimir putin's invasion of ukraine and
it is absolutely fascinating to see how
the standards that the right demands be
applied to the u.s mexico border
the very same right ignores
in the context of putin ignoring the
sovereignty of ukrainian borders even
though there are numerous accords that
say actually russia has to respect the
ukrainian borders and you really have to
see this to believe it yesterday we
looked at looked at clips from the day
before
in which
tucker carlson softly defended putin's
invasion by saying
ukraine's not even really a democracy
and ignoring the fact that when it came
to the u.s mexico border tucker sang a
very different tune well now we have
more examples candace owens now says
listen if we just listen to putin
uh we'd know
that uh this is actually
uh
not really putin's wrongdoing candace
owens tweeting yesterday quote i suggest
every american who wants to know what's
actually going on in russia and ukraine
read this transcript of putin's address
as i've said for months nato under the
direction from under direction from the
united states is violating previous
agreements and expanding eastward we are
at fault now multiple things there okay
first of all candace owens is saying
just read the transcript she's basically
saying listen to but if you don't speak
russian you have to read a translated
transcript
just listen if you want to know the
truth listen to what putin said two
nights ago
anybody who saw that and had a
transcript with them that they read
along which i did
should immediately recognize
that it was a confused
disheveled all over the place putin
rambling
nonsensically and completely failing to
justify in any legal or moral way
his invasion of ukraine but candace
owens is saying just listen to what the
authoritarian said and take him at his
word and then you'll understand what's
going on that's number one number two
i've already told you they are falsely
repeating this idea
that nato is violating agreements by
expanding eastward i've already talked
to you guys about this and you can go
back and look at my clip from last week
about this it is not true it is not true
that nato had committed
to not expand eastward there was
initially a verbal discussion made
during negotiations decades ago about
nato not expanding eastward and not ever
considering adding ukraine
those were
never codified and they were removed
before anything was signed now we can
have a reasonable conversation about if
you're russia
do you consider the eastward expansion
of nato and the consideration of maybe
someday ukraine will be part of nato if
you're russia could you consider that a
form of aggression sure we can have
that's absolutely something we can do
but this idea that
nato is just in the wrong here there was
an agreement there was no such agreement
next let's go to charlie kirk charlie
kirk sort of also softly runs
interference for putin by saying i don't
know guys i mean maybe it's an invasion
maybe it's not but they seem to kind of
be welcoming putin there why does putin
feel so empowered the entire western
world is putting sanctions right now on
russia as they call this an invasion
farewell might be i'm not the
i'm not the person to determine whether
that is an invasion or an annexation it
feels as if putin is going into places
that want him they have voted
overwhelmingly to be part of it it's a
family dispute that we shouldn't get in
the midst of that's for certain but why
does putin feel
as if
now's the perfect time right well he
definitely waited for the olympics to be
over for all the cheaters on his team
that we weren't even on the russian
federation team it was the russian
olympic committee
to be over with he didn't want the
spectacle in the midst of the olympics
he did annex crimea
after the olympics in um
2000 it's either 2006 or 2010 he has a
tendency to do this right after the
olympics or make uh big moves after that
i was trying to actually georgia was
after the olympics we'll get those dates
figured out
but why does putin feel so
let's say compelled at this particular
moment
to move
why even get close to this
so in a time when the entire planet is
locked down
due to the chinese coronavirus finally
the world is reopening
there's
one number in particular that vladimir
putin is looking at that his entire
economy is organized behind and that is
the petro dollar okay
so consider that charlie kirk from
turning point usa has been ranting for
years about mexico must respect our
borders they are our borders they are
internationally valid they must be
respected
but putin doesn't have to respect
ukraine's borders even though there are
actual agreements saying you have to
respect ukraine's borders come on guys
come on
and then lastly here's sort of a bonus
this is fox and friends fox and friends
actually um uh they admit putin is doing
a bad boy but they say it's joe biden's
fault putin is calling those troops
peacekeepers uh that's that's the phrase
one man's invader is another man's
peacekeeper but these two breakaway
regions have been disputed for eight
years they're not really breakaway they
were taken along the same time when
crimea was taken all and frankly the
reason that it's so precarious for
ukraine is even belarus on the on the
northern part it's a controlled uh it's
controlled by russia so on all look how
big that thing is yeah but they don't
it's gigantic it's the second biggest
country in that part of the world the
breadbasket and those those donbass
region is a huge energy resources
manufacturing resources it's been
coveted by vladimir putin and if you
listen to what he said i mean he the
words he used in that speech were no
different than any other uh autocrat of
the soviet union true i mean so like so
far they're basically right here that's
what he wants to be he's got one
playbook and the first time he's he's
gone to it again the putin playbook he's
done this before when he when he went
into uh when everything happened with
georgia
the experts are wondering if he's going
to stop with these regions and they
worry he wants to go farther and farther
and then eventually take over the black
sea china and taiwan are watching he
knows how biden handled afghanistan that
was a disaster he also lost two
embassies he's lost the afghanistan
embassy
and now the ukrainian embassy has moved
to poland when he was vice president
benghazi happened and even we know that
that's why this is happening guys it's
because benghazi happened when biden was
vp
and biden left afghanistan so now that's
why putin is doing this so no matter
what no matter what this is either
something that's fine
or
it's something that's not fine and it's
joe biden's fault that's the analysis
from right wing media we'll have these
clips on our instagram which you can
find at david pakman show
as someone who watches youtube you know
how annoying it is to watch ads at the
beginning of videos that are completely
irrelevant to the content you're
watching that's why you always click the
skip ad button our sponsor thought
leaders has just launched a new
targeting tool that allows advertisers
to choose the precise videos where their
ads will appear using the advanced
search in the thought leaders platform
which is powered by ai you can actually
find youtube videos relevant to your
brand's messaging and with thought
leaders precision targeting you can
really make every view count optimize
your ad spend improve your conversions
when brands put their ads on relevant
videos they catch their audience when
they are most receptive and create a
more fulfilling enjoyable youtube
experience for everyone involved plans
start at just sixty dollars a month but
you can try it now for just thirty
dollars for the first month when you
click the link below and use the code
pacman at checkout